this social media platform is a russian
state-owned alternative to youtube the
kremlin has been promoting the homegrown
network roottube as part of a battle for
russian users and their minds
that's because in the country social
media platforms have increasingly become
one of the main sources of information
challenging state television
youtube is the most important
platform for millions of people so we
examined the russian video platform at
the center of the kremlin's push to
attract users away from foreign networks
limiting their access to independent
news during the war in ukraine
owned by a russian state company ruetube
is a video platform almost as old as
youtube and visually very similar to it
and the kremlin has been outspoken about
its potential
since the war in ukraine started youtube
has been one of the last sources of
alternative news in russia
that's because instagram and facebook
are blocked in the country
that happened after the parent company
meta barred access to some state
channels in europe following requests
from the european union and british
authorities youtube remains available in
russia but there are concerns about its
future there
especially after the kremlin and rutube
have been on a mission to draw people
away from the american network
the company has partnered with some
popular vloggers and offered content
creators 100 of their revenue from ad
views during the first 40 days after
joining
the incentive came after youtube paused
monetization in russia as a response to
its aggression in ukraine this means
vloggers can no longer make money from
ad views from users in russia
a month later some popular russian
celebrities and vloggers who were on
youtube also started using ruetube
the platform's usership has also grown
as the kremlin encouraged government
departments universities and
state-backed media outlets to migrate
their content from youtube to roo-tube
the block
and moscow is investing in a new
generation of vloggers with a program
teaching russians how to become
successful on domestic platforms like
routine but the government support is
one reason some users don't feel like
switching
there is no trust to anything made by
the government
especially in order to replace something
already good and foreign
is a russian-speaking travel blogger and
journalist with more than one million
followers on youtube he says he's
skeptical about youtube replacing
youtube for russian viewers i just tried
to watch something or find something in
there and there was no views counters
under the videos
and data from analytics firm similar web
shows that there are fewer users on
youtube than on youtube in may rutube
had some 38 million visits a number
dwarfed by the nearly 2 billion visits
to youtube only from russia
some users can be put off by ruju
because of censorship concerns which
begin to emerge when uploading a video
according to roodtube's content curation
info page getting a video on the
platform can take up to 24 hours as its
moderation team watches every video
before other users can access it andrew
says it adheres to the observance of the
law and generally accepted norms of
morality
it couldn't be determined if all videos
go through human creation or how the
platform decides what videos to check
manually or automatically
any type of independent creators and
political activists cannot rely on
youtube gregory asmolov studies the
russian internet at king's college
london he says even if content that's
not aligned with the kremlin's rhetoric
made it onto youtube its algorithms
wouldn't promote it and that's why uh
youtube is used by those who are willing
to find some kind of space to express
their voice youtube also curates content
according to the company's community
guidelines its policies prohibit hate
speech misinformation and harmful or
dangerous content youtube also says it
uses human moderators and an upload
process that automatically screens for
potential issues before posting but the
uploading time is faster and the company
says it can take anywhere from a few
minutes to several hours based on the
file size and bandwidth
youtube didn't comment on its content
moderation criteria and the challenge
from rutube in russia youtube definitely
is still serving in russia the american
tech giant has said it's important to
let people in russia have access to
independent news
youtube will be blocked people in in
russia will be closed in a bubble of
just russian
information and just propaganda youtube
and its parent company gaspron media
didn't respond to a request for comment
about censorship and view count concerns
the kremlin said its promotion of rutube
started long before the conflict in
ukraine as it's always seen the
potential of the platform
as root tries to gain momentum and take
on youtube internet media experts say
it'll require a really important quality
that's one of the most difficult to
replicate
that lacks the global spirit of
user-generated content that you can see
on youtube therefore we can see that
youtube continues to be extremely
popular in russia and realty people is
not able to replace youtube as a local
alternative